[Music]
and when admitted a liar Alec Murdock
claimed innocence on the stand today he
seemed to be working very hard again it
was practiced so was it really a
choreographed performance or was it just
a heartfelt expression of remorse for
lying and then saying I didn't do it to
help answer that question we're joined
by Body Language expert Dr Lillian glass
Dr glass you've had so much experience
in the trial context examining Witnesses
so thank you for being with us here's
how Alec Murdoch described finding his
son's body
movies
he's done the way he's done it was a
wave it was
I could see you could see his brain
laying on the sidewalk oh it was so
he was so bad
so bad
Dr glass what are you seeing there
I see that there's not a lot of
authenticity I think he's practiced I
think he's uh it's it's not genuine I
don't feel that those are genuine tears
uh there may be remorse for getting
caught and for being in a trial but in
all honesty throughout this whole
experience you see you don't see a lot
of Tears you really see a lot of um
inauthenticity
was he trying to conjure up tears I mean
they're kind of looking down the the the
halting halting speech is that true is
he trying to make himself cry I didn't
see tears but I might have missed it yes
no you didn't miss a thing he's being
very dramatic uh looking down I mean
this is a great lawyer so he certainly
knows what to do but it's not working
because he's leaking out some of the
truth and as we go on further to watch
we do see some signals of deception
I want to play this next moment for you
to react to watch
you take this gun or any gun like it
and blow your son's brains out on June
7th or any day or any time
no I did not
when people say now did not that's
that's a big warning sign usually you
say no I didn't you know or you show
some emotion no I did not usually I
found in my experience that's always a
red flag
well so he was kind of nodding yes while
saying no is that what you're saying
that's one thing and then very hyper
articulate so again you know he's he's
being definite and trying to make his
point instead of saying no I didn't do
that you know like he's when when we
think back of how his son appeared which
was very genuine it's completely
different from Alex
now there was a moment where he explains
what he himself Alec Murdoch did when he
found his son's body
Mo you're a granny by the belt Luke
try to turn him over
and when I did
this phone popped out other I mean this
phone popped out
and
just picked it up and I put it right
back there
grabbed him by the belt loop that just
doesn't seem like anything anyone would
ever say ever but no and also what is
serious voice his oh sorry his voice
changed completely you heard a tone he's
you know all emotional and then all of a
sudden he goes back to normal and again
who grabs anybody by the belt loops this
is your son you grab him by the
shoulders by the by the head the upper
extremity not his belt loops I mean so
it doesn't ring true in terms of what
he's saying and you could see it in his
face
well Dr glass is that trying to impart a
sense of specificity onto the scene
that's why you would say that if you
were being less than honest or lying
exactly that's one of the signals of
deception it's too much information he's
getting too detailed that's not what
people would say they'd say oh my gosh
those brains were all over the place
there was blood it was horrible but
that's not what he's doing he's focusing
on the belt loops and as he goes on
further uh he he talks about the the
cell phone falling out of the belt loop
or the the belt area and it's just too
much information that's a big warning
sign when it comes to deception
Dr glass fascinating thank you so much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else